I want to to address today the the the
global order so the globalization
process built from the point of view of
the developing world so my my focus a
will be what are the let's say be the
opportunities have the challenges and
particularly you know as we will see
throughout the lecture the some of the
major institutional issues that relate
they say to the to the way developing
countries feel in the global order now
if you from that perspective I may start
by saying that you know in a sense we
have lived through two opposite abuse of
this question of development the the
traditional view which goes back to they
said to David Ricardo which amuse in a
sense the International economy a as a
system in which equal partners
relate to each other and specialize
according to their you know comparative
advantages the traditional theory goes
now there are in a sense of many
versions of data and you could even say
that the very you know popular book by
by Thomas Friedman day the world is flat
is a sort of a view or that sort and
your possible which is in a note were
largest and the one that I'm going to
present today is rather the view of the
international system really as a
hierarchical system as a a system in
which unequal partners relate to each
other and which of course from that
perspective poses very specific
challenges to the design of of the
architecture so beautiful at that point
of you I would like to start by
introducing
says that the three critical issues try
to interpret some of the results that I
will present and then you know go back
to the institutional arrangements and
try to see from the point of view or the
the sale of the design of international
institutions but also from the point of
view of the specific issues that relate
to the International agenda you know how
you know we can see this issue of the
management of the inter links between
the developing countries and the global
order so I will start by by presenting
you know you know some facts that relate
to you know to the three when I call the
three critical issues in the
international economic order the first
one is that markets are very unevenly
liberalized we'll see through the
comparison of different previous in
history you know what I am talking about
the second is the and the one which I
will dwell in for a bit longer in this
initial part of the presentation is that
the benefits of the of the globalization
process are very unevenly distributed
both among nations and among citizens
and I would say that you know to a large
extent this you know these outcomes
relate to to a third critical issue
which is the fact that there is a
significant lag in the development of
the global institutions into to manage
the global markets and in a sense we in
that regard we we are leaving some of
the issues that were faced by many
nations a moistur learning history
before the the rise of the of the state
institutions to market the effects of
markets for instance the development of
the social welfare state or the
development of the
market regulation and different forms
which were the the ways by which
particularly the industrial economies
were able to manage some of the
downsides of markets that a state early
state in which this institutions were
not developed generating many a
difficulties both economic and social
which were faced by the rising or the
rise of a state institutions well at the
global level we are seeing that a stage
because we we haven't we don't have now
the sort of institutions that are
required to manage you know the
downsides of global markets now when I
talk about these institutional issues
mase may say that I am in a sense
referring to at least five difficult
questions the first I will go back at
the end of my lecture in particular to
this issue that we have an incomplete
and biased agenda but aside from that I
may say we have also an incomplete set
of institutions there are areas of
international or the international
system which lack institutions and even
when we have institutions there is a
significant they say asymmetry between
the roles that these institutions have
been given and the instruments that they
have been provided with so for instance
you know you can say that you know in
the in relation for instance to some of
the the the only way with the social
international social agenda has been
reflected which is the the United
Nations Millennium Development Goals you
know that objective really lacks any
counterpart in terms of the instrument
that the United Nation has to to make
that you know object you know those set
of objective
effective then we have in many of this
area's a fourth a sort of issue which we
will see is it's actually quite
important for some of the many questions
that we're going to to ask ourselves
today which is the where I can call the
unsettled relation between globalization
and the nation-state in a sense we are
building we have been building an
international system not a transnational
system of institutions I mean there are
some cases in which a set of a
transnational institutions have been
created for instance in Europe you know
with the European Union and the European
Commission which has a specific set of
powers which I you know overall member
or member states of the European Union
but aside from those limited examples
and I probably outside for that a
specific example we are building a
system an international system which
there is a system based on nations or
nation-states
now one of the very peculiar
characteristics of that system is that
nation states have been weakening at the
same time so we're building a system in
which we still have a very unsettled
relation between the international the
global order and the nation-state and
finally I'm very importantly also we
still have a system in who is developing
countries have very limited voice and
participation in decision-making the
fact that you know is reflected in in
all of the major fora starting you know
with the World Bank and the IMF but you
know going to many other institutions
and even to the major immortally say the
most powerful institution that you
nineteen Nations which is the UN
Security Council now to understand the
the you know this well I mentioned first
which was the very young a very uneven
liberalisation of markets it's
interesting to see they say the you know
the global order as as many historians
have seen as as having gone through
three different stages on one
intermediate stage between the first and
the second which was really the collapse
or the first global world so we have a
first globalization you know drawing
let's say from 1870 to 1913 they
collapse in the interwar period then
giving rise to a second phase of
globalization from they say they at the
end of the Second World War to 1973 and
then you know they say the the sort of
process that we have been living through
since the mid 1970s now if we look at
the at the last column here and compare
with the previous ones let's say that
you know the very specific
characteristics or the current system is
the high capital mobility so capital is
very free to move among nations and the
third line what I call extensive free
trade now in the first area that is in
in relation to the to the capital
mobility we have a system which is very
similar to the first globalization in
the third in the area of trade we have
actually much more liberalized trade
today than we ever had in history it is
not true that the first mobilization was
a world of free trade there were agents
of free trade such as Great Britain but
there were also major protectionist
nations starting with the United States
of America and going through continental
Europe and Latin America being you know
during that phase you know very
protectionist nations so actually the
all of the first globalization was
actually one of limited free trade you
know from that perspective we certainly
have today the most liberalized trade
regime ever in history now at the same
time you see that we have you know what
I call growing and segmented labor
mobility by growing we will see that in
fact you know a labor has been has
become increasingly mobile after
collapsing both in the interworld period
and in the first globally in the second
globalization you know there has been an
extensive movement towards labor
mobility but it is still you know
limited and very importantly segmented
in a different way to the way it was
segmented during the first globalization
where labor was probably more mobile
than today the the segmentations that we
have today are basically segmentations
according to the skills of workers so
steam workers are much more mobile than
unskilled workers or to be precise on
his skill workers can only mobile a you
know move largely in an irregular or as
he said in the united states in an
illegal manner I prefer the term
irregular to illegal because you know
people are not never illegal okay so
that so the irregular form in critical
you know labor mobility takes place in
the first globalization is interesting
that the major forms of segmentation
were were according to the origin of
migrants so essentially ancient migrants
move in a different way from European
migrants you know while European
migrants migrated to the United States
you know Canada let's say Australia New
Zealand were Argentina in a fairly free
manner Asians were generally forbidden
at some point from migrating into those
places so that asians really migrated to
the tropics basically in South Asians to
Africa and to some tropical parts of
Latin America
and the Caribbean now in terms of the
last two issues I would say that the
essential characteristic of global
institutions is as I said that they were
they are lagging behind that's a
different characteristic I think from
the the second globalization and the
first globalization the first
globalization we essentially had no
major international institutions in the
second or the word the birth of some
institutions which were not you know
very limited in scope in the second
institution on the other hand there was
you know at the end of the Second World
War a major effort to create new
institutions to manage a new a global
order which was the only you know the
United Nations the or you know the World
Bank the International Monetary Fund as
many as well as many other institutions
now that the institutions that we have
today in a sense are the same that we
herded but you know from the second
globalization but they have not been
able they have not adapted yet to the
challenges or they're posed by this
third globalization and finally in terms
of the national institutions I will say
that the main characteristics or the or
the or this third globalization is what
I call the globe the growing
standardization of institutions that's a
big the big difference to the previous
two phases in which it was openly
recognized that international
institutions could be very different
from each other
so there was no attempt or and no forces
that generated a harmonious
modernization of institutions now built
from the point of view of the unequal
distribution of benefits well we have
let me go through the through the graphs
is first of all what I call the what is
has been called the divergence big time
so a long term divergence between
industrial and developing countries that
starts during the first globalization
and has not yet stopped you know in this
graph
can see particularly in the first the
they why the white columns relate to the
they say the developing countries while
the blue columns relate to industrial
countries so the in the first the first
two periods the first period they say
basically covers the first globalization
and the second cover the interwar period
developing countries lack significantly
behind now that was so what a contracted
during the second globalization so
generally there was a big boom also
called by many people the Golden Age of
you know post-war development in which
you know industrial countries grew very
fast and developing countries had the
first boom ever in history now in the
succeeding faces a actually developing
countries started to lag also behind
again behind a particularly those
outside Asia so you particularly see the
the black columns at the end basically
delayed to the growth or the you know or
the in the average developing country
it varies very much less than the
industrial countries which are again in
in blue so the result of that is that we
have a long-term increase in
international inequalities this growth
this shows two measures of international
inequalities in the post-war period
until 2001 as we will see the the recent
period is some part are typical in
history the the red line shows the ratio
between the per capita income of the
OECD that is the industrial economies
and sub-saharan Africa
so there's true the two extremes of the
international distribution of income as
you can see there has been as a
persistent increase in the gap between
industrial economies and sub-saharan
Africa now the blue shows the let's say
the average developing country so the
story there is it's a bit different as
you
see there has been also almost
persistent increase in inequality with
you know one exception which is the
period between 1973 and 1980 but aside
from that also the average developing
country has lagged behind the industrial
world so the you know build you know on
over long periods of time as we saw in
the previous graph prior to 1950 there
have been a significant divergence of
income and generally speaking on average
there has also been an increase in
increasing divergence of incomes since
since the 1950s so the recent period the
period going particularly from nineteen
assuming from 2004 to 2007 it's actually
the first period in which we see a very
high diverging advantage of developing
countries this is the first period in
history you can say in who in developing
countries are growing significantly
above industrial economies now does this
represent a breaking history may say we
don't know yet
it may it may particularly because you
know a China and India in particular
have become engines of his own or their
own and it may be that you know they can
constitute you know an alternative
engine of the world economy but you know
so far in history that you know a sort
of performance has not been evidence for
a long period of time I guess we will
see in the next crisis where this is
true or not in particular now build from
the point of view or the distributional
benefits among among citizens not among
nations as in the previous graphs what
is striking is how much a income
distribution has become unequal
throughout the whole world now based on
on a study by the United Nations
University I estimate here you know what
is the percentage of the
population of the world that lives in
countries with income inequality has
risen or has fallen basically over the
last three decades and the conclusion is
that eighty eight percent of the
population of the world lives in
countries where inequality is increasing
so increasing inequality within nations
is even a more pervasive phenomenon in a
sense than in increasing inequality
among nations particularly because among
nations at least we have the opposite
phenomenon of some major developing
countries growing very fast china over
now over 25 years and India in a shorter
period of time now on the contrary
according to this estimates less than 3%
or the population of the world live in
countries where income distribution
improved in the last three decades of
the 20th century so this is a very
pervasive phenomena that you know we see
here in turns in this next graph in
terms of the you know the effects that
that has had on income inequality in the
world so while you know the income
inequality of the world may have
improved particularly due to the rise of
China in part in the in the world
economy at the same time it is true that
you know income inequality within
countries has been an increasing source
of world inequality since then you know
since 1980 at least now a third
phenomenon that the affects you know
developing countries you know relate to
some social issues and I just you know
mentioned two here the first one is that
the development of a let's say of a
social welfare state is a you know is
highly associated with the income level
of countries so if we see here the you
know the
spending the socialist spending as a
proportion of the you know all the size
of the economies we see that you know we
have the three corners for low-income
middle-income and high-income countries
so the high-income countries generally
have the the instantly a very
sophisticated set of institution to
manage the the affects of markets and to
promote a social development while you
know this is not true particularly of
low-income countries and many
middle-income countries are really
struggling to develop those institutions
so the the capacity of nation-states to
contract markets by themselves you know
really depends on the level of income of
countries and the second which is say
you know is has many phases to it but
this is one phase in the fact that the
global economy has experienced major
problems in terms of generating enough
employment opportunities so one of the
faces of that problem in developing
countries is what I call here rising
labor market dualism that is the growth
of the informal relative to the formal
economies so the different you know
precarious you know forms of employment
that have been becoming increasingly
common in the developing world and which
of course are forcing itself you know in
another ways to you know to generate an
outflow of labor from the developing to
the developed world which we'll see
later in the in terms of graphs you see
here is the compulsion the 1980s in red
with the 1990s in bloom and we see that
you know while in the you know
industrial countries we should the
second sort of grab the you know
informality has been declining slightly
in all regions of the developing world
it has been increasing in the you know
or the increase in the 1990s now how you
know how do I interpret these facts so
the my interpretation of these facts
which you know you have in the reading
from from
that I wrote the you know for some four
years ago in that you know we have to
understand this as I said in the
beginning as the result of some you know
inequalities in the global order which I
call here the the three basic symmetries
of the global order now the the three
essential symmetries which are
characteristic of this period don't
answer your previous periods of
globalization are you know first of all
the financial and macroeconomic as
symmetries now the financial and
macroeconomic as symmetries at the end
of the day relate to two fundamental
facts to the fundamental fact that the
money of the world the major money for
the world our money from industrial
countries not from developing countries
so the center of the global economy is
the one that provides international
currencies particularly the US dollar
now that generates through many
mechanisms Arango I'm not going to
explain some a to other problems the
first the first is the the phenomenon of
financial market segmentation financial
markets discriminate between what they
consider good borrowers and bad
borrowers or less risky and more risky
borrowers so that developing countries
are usually classified at the in the
category of riskier borrowers and that
generates as we will see a third problem
which is the difficulty that developing
countries have you know to manage the
very strong financial cycles that they
face due to this phenomenon so the first
one is in a sense a problem that
generates a in the terminology of
economies very Pro cyclical behavior you
know developing countries are subject to
strong business cycles and have been
limited room of maneuver to manage those
cycles we will see that you know in some
graphs and David
the second which has like I mean that
guy that I would say that that first has
him it it's actually very characteristic
or the current order it was not
characteristic of the first two
globalization's you know I I will not
explain that in detail the second
actually has been in or characteristic
of all phases of globalization and I
call it denote the technological and
productive as symmetries now this
problem relates to the fact that the
major engine of world economic growth is
technological change but technical
change is very highly concentrated in a
few countries of the world so in a few
industrial economies most of the newgen
new technologies are generated and there
is a very complex process but which you
know that technology is disseminated
throughout another world economic system
and that process let me say is not a
smooth one and and requires that there
is a continuous transfer of production
activities toward the developing world
particularly you know primary sector
activities and so manufacturing
activities and it's a process that does
not work is smoothly among other reasons
because industrial countries protect
those sectors which they should you know
are Dakini in the industrial economies
and should be transferred but they try
to avoid in order process due to many
you know internal pressures that they
face including the internal political
pressures and the third problem is the
asymmetry in the degree of mobility of
factors of production and this issue
remains in particular to the fact that
capital it's much more mobile than labor
and particularly than unskilled labor
now the major implication of that fact
as you know I think that they someone
particularly in some of the work by
Danny Broderick has shown is that there
is a bias in income distribution against
the less mobile factors and in favor the
more mobile factors so the tendency of
world income
to favor you know the more mobile
factors particularly capital and to some
extent still neighbor may be related to
the fact that the international economy
discriminates against labor mobility and
particularly against then you know
mobility of unskilled a so let me go
through some of the most you know some
of the ways in which these are
symmetries are manifested this is the
unstability of Finance for developing
countries particularly look at the line
this is the availability of finance for
developing countries you can see the you
know back there you know the end of the
boom of the 1970 then the debt crisis
then the boom of the 1980s which ended
with the Asian crisis and then the
recent boom of financing so now of
course they you know we are experiencing
in the developing world a true flood of
capital but we have experienced in the
past order floats of capital the problem
is that the floats of capital are you
know followed by by very dry weather so
is the instability of finance the fact
that we alternate between extremely good
finances and extremely under lack of
financing that generates very strong
swings in the developing world and this
is seen from the point of view of the
cost of capital so the the periods of
crisis are reflected here in peaks in
the cost of financing so you know you
know if we combine the two graphs we
will see that the previous equation
financing is available the cost of
financing for the periods in which
financing is not available are periods
in which financing becomes very
expensive so we alternate between
periods in which financing is good
unless an available at very low cost
with producing which is not available
and whatever is available is available
at very high cost so in this particular
swings in financing that you know are
you know the manifestation of that first
asymmetry that I was mentioning now this
is one so you say well why don't
developing countries you know
there are you know develop you know
policy instruments to try to counter the
cycle well the point is they cannot they
generally cannot they have very limited
room of manoeuvre to do that and one way
to see that is this particular in a
table in which is teammate how cyclical
is fiscal policy and we see you know in
the table you see the countries have
counter-cyclical fiscal policies so they
tend to that means that they tend to
increase public sector spending during
crisis and trend to moderate public
sector spending to their boobs so fiscal
policy tends to smooth business cycles
in the developing world the opposite is
true in regions or the developing world
have either what I call moderately Pro
cyclical policies so you know actually
fiscal policy moves or reinforces the
business cycle and no region in the
developing world has a counter-cyclical
fiscal policy as industrial firms so
this these are manifestations of that so
that developing countries are subject to
stalls
to strong very strong cyclical swings in
the international economy and I think
there is a lot of evidence in you know
it's a massive literature that actually
has shown that business cycle has have
tended to become smoother in industrial
countries in developing in the
developing world actually the evidence
is the opposite that business cycle had
become sharper you know more stronger
now one cart racing which I don't have
time to dwell it is this very peculiar
result or the in the post Asian crisis
which is say you know is water flowing
uphill
you know finance it was traditionally
said should flow from the industrial
countries to the developing world
and that was supposed to be a way to
smooth out you know the amido to reduce
a global inequalities well the opposite
is true
and has been increasingly sauce and
sauces the Asian crisis so the net
transfer of resources from developing
countries to an industrial world reach
last year 800 billion dollars now the
reason for that I would say the basic
reason for that is that since developing
countries have learned that they are
subject to strong cycles of finance they
have decided to use the current good
financial conditions to accumulate what
has come to be called self insurance so
they basically they have been
accumulating massive amount of
international reserves to manage the
next crisis and the manifestation one of
the major manifestations of that you
know together I guess with other
phenomenon I'm not going to explain as
fairly basically with high commodity
prices but the result of that is that
you know developing countries actually
instead of receiving net financing from
the industrial countries are actually
financing the industrial countries and
particularly the United States now in
the trade area I would say the major
problem the major problem that we have
is that they the opportunities tend to
be very only unevenly distributed among
the developing countries and this first
of all the the only way in which they
say the technological transfer can be
done smoothly from the let's say from
the industrial country throughout the
developing world it's actually to have a
parallel process by which economic
activities are transferred now that
process has two problems first of all
that industrial countries tend to block
you know that transfer by protecting
basically agriculture and protecting you
know some light manufacturers which are
labor intensive okay so that's one
phenomenon and the second phenomena is
that the opportunities to adopt
particularly manufacturing activities
are not even are not distributed evenly
among
developing countries so some developing
countries which have already some level
of development are much better at trying
to attract those activities than the
average developing helps so for all the
velop in countries there are always some
opportunities particularly opportunities
to produce primary goods but the
opportunities produce manufacturers are
not evenly distributed among the
developing countries now the result is
important because as you can see here
there is strong evidence that the
developing countries that are able to
industrialize and particularly in recent
periods to industrialized towards
highness you know high-tech
manufacturers do much better in terms of
economic growth than those developing
countries that are unable to do so so
the you know the columns on the Left I
mean do you have called two columns here
it what happened between 1962 and 1980
and then from what happened between 1980
and 2000 and what you see here is that
in the earlier periods of time well you
know in all periods of time the the
countries that are basically specialized
in primary commodity or in natural
resource base manufacturers that base
manufactures based on the processing of
natural resources those countries tend
to grow much less much less than
countries that industrialize in and in
the recent period is basically countries
that move into high-tech manufacturers
that can grow relatively fast now again
this has changed during the recent
period of time basically because natural
resources have become an opportunity
again you know for many developing
countries so the in in the recent period
the story you know is slightly different
to this but over you know long period of
time it is basically the opportunity
industrialized that has become an
opportunity now that opportunity has not
been available to all developing
countries and particularly low-income
countries have fallen behind in that
process and finally looking at my third
asymmetry
I you know this graph shows that in many
ways migration remains remains more
limited than during the first
globalization so I have here the number
of migrants as a proportion of total
population a different points in history
you know nineteen ten thirty sixty and
two thousand huh when you see here you
know are in a basically two phenomenon
aside from Western Europe you know
Western Europe was a source of migration
and they let's say in the late 19th
century and early 20th century and has
only become a source of you know
emigration in recent days so you know
aside from from Western Europe actually
you know the number of migrants as a
proportion of the total population
remains today below the levels reached
in 1910 and that is a first
characteristic or differ in all the the
traditional context of immigration I
mean this means the the US Canada
Australia New Zealand you know where you
know this basically the pattern of the
u.s. so a significant fall in the
proportion of migrants from 1910 to 1960
and then a recovery to levels which
remains significantly below you know
1910 but it's also a very much of the
caricature of the other destination of
European migrants in the late 19th early
20th century which was South America so
Argentina and Uruguay so then we see a
josa collapse and you can see the
proportion of migrants in Argentina and
worldwide was much higher than the u.s.
let's say in the in the first
globalization so overall yes there is
this increasing mobility of Labor but
mobility but the proportion of migrants
remained below well so they actually in
you estimated not in this way by by by
looking at you know Pacific moment of
time but actually by looking at previous
and the contribution of migration to
population growth you will find out
actually that migration was much more
important in the first globalization
than it is it is today
now you know with this background in
mind let me try to reflect on on what
should be the you know the sort of you
know objectives of International
Cooperation some of the issues of
international cooperation so I define in
a you know in my work what I call the
three basic objectives of international
cooperation which relate to different
aspects of the open Internet penance but
you know which is characteristic of the
global order but the first the first
objective is the management the excuse
me the management of in the
interdependence as such and this has to
do with what we economists have called
the supply of global public goods global
public goods are basically goods are
provided to manage interdependence
interdependence associated for instant
to the to the economy presently the
macro economy to the you know financial
psychosom you know a macro economic
cycles in general to trade and also you
have to provide some institutions to
coordinate you know global trade
particularly you know there the WTO in
recent periods but also to other issues
they say environmental issues have
become increasingly important as global
public goods so the management of
climate change it can be considered to
be one of the you know a issues of
global public goods now aside from the
issue of interdependence there are
however two other issues which I call
the issue of the quality of nations and
the issue of equality of citizens now
the issue of equality of nations you
know respond to them you know to what I
have presented today the fact that you
know nations are very you know our you
know star
that's our part of a hierarchical system
so they are really unequal the
opportunities that they face are very
unequal and and they are particularly
unequal according to the level of
development so low-income countries
generally have much more difficulties
than middle-income countries in relating
to the global economy and say
middle-income countries in turn have
much more difficulties than the
high-income countries in related to the
global economy so this issues basically
relate to you know how to overcome the
asymmetry of the global order that I
mentioned before that is the macro the
the technological and the inequalities
in the mobility of factors of production
and the third issue relates at the end
to how we transplant to the global order
what was the origin of the nation-state
or the modern nation-state which is the
quality of citizens that is how we build
an international system of the set of
Rights which is they say the the best
expression of the citizens the divided
citizen has rights and is equal to
others in insofar as she or he has
rights that you know how that agenda or
the Equality of citizens is transplanted
to the world economy so in this regard
we are concerned not only with citizens
of developing countries but also even
with citizens of industrial countries
which may be unfairly treated by the
global economic holder so how to manage
that you know they say the losers of
globalization as individuals or as
families which may be located any part
of the global economy I will probably
argue more frequently in developing
countries but also in you know in
industrial towns now so we will see
several issues of the International
agenda that reflect to some extent
different parts of this of these
objectives so may combine you know
the first to order may relate to the
third as we will see now before I do
that however it is actually interesting
and going back to my my first you know
presentation about the the problems with
institutions that you know what is the
sort of governance structures that that
we should build and I would say you know
those governance structures have to
respond a to to this to the
heterogeneity of the system and other
there is a first a question of the
relation between the global and the
regional and sub-regional institutions
so my first point is that a system built
on a denser network of institutions is
peripheral to a system based on few
institutions because of the
heterogeneity of the system so that's
why there is a row here and a
significant role for regional and
sub-regional institutions and also for
national you know for national
institutions so it has to be a system
that takes into account the different
orders or and the heterogeneity of that
order and you know that denser system is
likely to be better to manage the global
order that just having a few
international institutions so this is
not a question in that regard or
building one big nation the same global
state really or building a network of
institutions that perform the functions
of the state now insofar as the system
is international that is by and by that
I mean based on nation-states there are
some very specific characteristics or
you know what is allowed for
nation-states and in that regard there
are two particular questions or two
particular issues excuse me the first
one is what you know particularly the
United Nations
has come to court because the policy
space so nation space have to be allowed
sufficient space to manage the effects
that globalization has on their citizens
and the second is that you know the
responses in a democratic order are not
necessarily going to be the same in
different nations so a second
characteristic of the you know or that
order has to be the global institutions
should be firmly respectful of diversity
okay and I'll actually finish with that
specific point and the third problem in
the governance structure that we know
today is the fact that the participation
of developing countries is on equitable
it's on equitable in particularly in the
powerful institutions and it's actually
non-existent in some institutions I mean
it's on equitable in the Security
Council of the United Nations is on
equitable in the IMF and the World Bank
they have been discussing that issue in
but it's a very even be even more in it
could inequitable in other institutions
such as the Bank of International
Settlements
and it's non-existent in some areas for
instance in the design of global
financial rules or global you know or
global accounting standards there is
absolutely no participation of any
developing country so there's a basic
problem of what you know in new and
jargon came to be called the voice and
participation or developing countries in
you know in decision making so you know
these are you know different issues that
we see in the global world today
now we done in mind particularly you
know taking in mind the the three basic
objectives of international cooperation
let me reflect on some of the areas of
international cooperation so let me
start with you know macroeconomic and
finance I mean what what are we talking
about
well there are some issues that relate
to the global public with the provision
of global public goods and the second
set of issues that relate to their
symmetries - that you know macroeconomic
and financial asymmetry that we saw
before so in relation to the first
problem we need a you know a system that
you know provide some macroeconomic
coherence in the world economy we don't
have one and we're seeing that issue
today in the past this was always solved
through ad hoc arrangements among major
powers so there was a big crisis in the
1980s you know there was a what was the
PASOK or you know among the major
countries to see how to manage in
particular the issue of u.s. deficits
now we have seen today and there is the
attendant International Monetary Fund in
recent years - to act in a sense in that
you know in that character now including
other major countries which come from
the developing world particularly China
and the oil-producing countries now but
that system is extremely dysfunctional
today so we have absolutely no mechanism
in the world to guarantee that
macroeconomic policies among you know
major countries are consistent among
each other so they you know there may be
you know significant crisis associated
to that and actually we're facing
cyclical problems we have faced cyclical
problems in 1980s and today basically
associated to the imbalances of the US
economy but the second issue is
financial regulation this there is
clearly an on the regulation of finance
we shall become in actually quite
evident in recent months in the in the
financial crisis of the United States
you know the you know certain activities
social do you know the hedge funds and
others they are unregulated and and
there are many you know instruments
available in the market that generated a
lot of risk which are not either subject
to most regulation so you know those are
issues of the provision of global public
goods the the international economy
still lags
a system for macroeconomic coherence and
it still lacks a good system - you know
for financial regulation or the
increasingly globalized world of finance
but there also is sort of problems
associated to the particular
vulnerabilities of developing countries
that relate to the availability of hands
for poor countries this is an area which
there has been advanced in recent years
you know official development assistance
has been growing I wanted to have a
graph but it was not very much up today
so I didn't put it here but there is
clearly in the last four years a very
large increase in financing it still is
highly insufficient for the meeting some
of the major challenges of poor
countries a second issue is the issue of
availability of financing during crisis
now the International Monetary Fund was
created for that purpose but it has been
you know subject to high levels of
criticism due to the way it has provided
finance in a very conditional manner and
in manif which you know most developing
countries consider to be highly
unsatisfactory so this issue is again
you know in in the international agenda
then we have more broadly in the issue
that we lack in our global financial
safety net now in the you know for many
years
you know since particularly since the
crisis in 1930s
you know industrial countries or
actually at the national level all
countries develop a financial safety net
when as a safety net is basically a way
to finance do to manage the crisis of
major financial institution now that is
provided by the central banks in
countries there is nothing like that in
the international economy and also
national systems have bankruptcy
procedures ways of managing you know in
a legal order you know the bankruptcies
there is nothing like that in the global
economy so there are many issues and and
that of course is is particularly issue
of particularly because it is developing
countries or different character that
have had you know surprise so the only
solutions have been
an ad hoc character to - you know that
you know I thought characters such as
the Brady plan which was the sign in the
late 90s for managing you know the Latin
American debt crisis or the highly that
that poor countries initiative which was
the sign you know about ten years ago to
manage the the crisis of the poor
countries but there is no regular
mechanism that no institutional
mechanism in place to manage a in our
crisis now a second set of things to
relate to trade now in trade we do have
a you know the the form of a or the
global public good that is a system of
regulations for world trade which is the
the World Trade Organization but there
are significant problems associated to
the to the rules as they relate to
developing countries and I'm you know
these are issues some of which having
you know emphasized by the developing
countries in 1960s others are of more
recent origin the first issue is the
constraints on development posed by
intellectual property rights now since
since the technology originates
essentially in industrial countries and
the the fact that you know that activity
is highly protected by international
regulation has become increasing source
of concern and since many developing
countries in the past and even
industrial countries developed by
intellectual piracy of some sort to use
the current terminology there is by
copying you know technology you know
developed before you know you can say
that you know continental Europe you
know to a large they benefited from that
Japan certainly benefited from you know
the possibility of you know copying
technology and some of them you know
originally you know Asian Tigers also on
latin-american industrialization in the
front
fifty-two the nineteen seventies
benefited a lot by you know by using by
copying technology now that is much more
limited today in you know in the World
Trade Organization and the cost of
Technology has become an increasing
source of constraint for developing
comes the second issues as I mentioned
the only way to transfer knowledge in
technology in the world it's a transfer
economic activities now
that is brought in a different way so
there are you know another set of issues
associated to that which are re cultural
subsidies the the the issues called
tariff escalation and protection for
labor intensive manufacture this relate
to the fact that the more process a good
is the hybrid tariff it faces you know
in the when traded with industrial
countries the stolid escalation I'm the
protection of labor intensive
manufacturing the fact that you know
delayed more labor intensive
manufacturers such as apparel leather
goods etc are solid also to higher
levels of protection in industrial
countries and the third issue is in a
world which is moving increasingly to a
trade of services it is quite clear that
the services in which developing
countries have potentially more stronger
advantage which has you know unskilled
labor intensive services where these are
basically tourist services you know it
can be construction services you know
those services are not allowed to be
provided internationally that is for
instance you cannot you know forensic
assign a construction company you know
in a low-income country that you know is
able to bring you know its workforce you
know an industrial economy to the
construction that is not generally
allowed in the world today on the
contrary you know you have a financial
service or a telecommunication service
you are allowed in you know to enter
your labor force which is generally
skilled in to a developing country so
there is a very uneven liberalization of
services associated to that fact
and they and the final point has to do
with an all issue which is the the room
of maneuver for active production sector
strategies now you know as the reading
from haedongcheong that you have shows
you know in the past a you know it was
quite common to use a protection or you
know subsidies of different sort to
industrialize now with the current World
Trade Organization the room to do that
has been significantly constrained now
in the global environmental area you
know I will just mention I mean there
are many many issues that relate to the
I mean this is essentially global public
good issue so you know it is quite clear
that the issue of you know climate
change the issue of biodiversity in
particular are you know essentially
global you know issues of global
provision of global public goods at the
same time however there are significant
problems of how you know developing
country related an agenda now insofar as
image the the the source of emission of
greenhouse gases has essentially come
historically from industrial countries
you know the developing countries have
been posing the question of how the cost
of combatting climate change is going to
be distributed among countries I mean
other areas such as you know forests or
biodiversity the major issue is you know
the fact that you know the major sources
avoid biodiversity and forests are now
in the developing world so if we want to
protect you know those natural resources
what are the international transfers
that will you know make that possible
now for set of issues relate to the you
know what you can say is the lack of of
a global social agenda in the
institution that we have developed for
international cooperation you know some
issues of economic character or
you know social finance and trade some
issues or the environmental character
had become increasingly an agenda this
the social agenda almost has no
institutions or rather has the
institutions that are very weak in their
capacity to influence there are many
United Nations institutions you can say
they know they know they know
International Labour Organization and
UNICEF etc etc that have a you know were
created for this purpose but the
instrument that they have are extremely
limited relative to the challenge that
the wall economy has in this area so I
would say that the seeds of a truly
international social of noble social
agenda have only come relatively late
with the Millennium Declaration and the
Millennium Development Goals now however
we have no institutions that will
guarantee you know how you know the the
provision of those or the achievement of
those Millennium Development Goals that
is we don't have a well designed system
of official development cooperation that
is a multilateral in character that has
you know in which you know the
recipients have rights you know which is
very different from let's say what
happens at the national level
you know the backward regions generally
have a right to transfers there have
been designed by policies and you know a
poor citizens have generally have some
rights instance or the systems by which
they are protected and more broadly you
know the only social protection systems
remain in the domain of nation-states
and we have no is it it still no is the
global institutions to see how you know
those in how we encourage the
development of social protection systems
and how those social protection systems
are made to interact with each other on
countries on taxation so there has to be
you know the coordination of global
taxation has become increasingly goal a
global probably good
and we if we don't assign systems of
cooperation
you know cope you know competition you
know to produce tax rates to attract
investment may actually reduce the
sources of financing for social
protection systems which are
increasingly required for a global
economy that generates risk we have no
rules to manage global competition you
know antitrust regulations were you know
design a particularly under the
leadership of the United States
you know since early in the 20th century
to manage the problem you know they they
say they uncompetitive practices of some
firms there is no system to manage the
uncompetitive fine practices or
multinational firms in the global
economy there is no mechanism to
facilitate technology transfer if
anything we have now in place a system
that constrains technology or make
costly technology transfer and finally
there is no compensatory mechanism to
facilitate the convergence of countries
that lag behind in the global economy
now you know in countries I mean just to
mention that they have always been
systems to transfer physical resources
to the less developed regions of the
other country and the European Union
established that for the European Union
so in a region that are lagging behind
they have no incomes per capita they
have access to a special financing you
know that's you know helped to
accelerate the you know the development
there is nothing like that in the global
economy so the global agenda in other
words have you know incomplete elements
and absent elements but we do have you
know a huge agenda in front to you know
to design a system in which the
institutional development is compatible
to the growth of global markets and
finally you know let me say that
whatever system with a sign we have to
you know always have in mind that you
know the nation-state is going to be at
the center
and the nation-state will be for a long
time to come
they made your place where democracy
plays a role so an international system
has to be firmly respectful of diversity
I'm filming with respectful of the fact
there is no universal path to
development and that the choice of
citizens well rather than citizens
should have a choice over the economic
and social institutions that they have
in their own country okay thank you very
much